hey I'm Ryan and I'm Sam and we're here
to talk about huge news just throw it
it's the best Star Wars rumor about news
that's going to break yes sir
so deadline just reported that there's
gonna be an announcement that Ryan
Johnson is going to be writing a
directing episode 8 and possibly episode
9 yeah 9 is up in the air maybe they'll
give it to Josh Trank maybe they'll give
it to David Fincher knows maybe it'll
just be a game of like you pass it off
to the greatest directors in the world
this is super I was super excited about
JJ
this is beyond JJ he seemed like an
obvious choice ryan johnson for those of
you who don't know directed brick
Brothers Bloom and looper yeah all of
which are brilliant films this is not a
crazy choice but it's a pseudo risky
choice and an interesting yet which is
the most exciting it is a guy who has
worked with you know reasonably large
budgets but nothing this huge and also
his movies don't with the exception of
looper probably don't have the national
recognition they would go with have you
wanted to save choice yeah and again and
the fact that he's not safe but he's
obviously a brilliant filmmaker so he's
safe that way but there is a certain
risk involved in terms of he's not a
household name like JJ is yes I've had a
huge budget like this um it makes it the
most interesting choice they've made out
of any of them so very fancy and it's
just one more brick in the giant edifice
that's being built of people being
excited about Star Wars yeah everything
they've done so far has just ramped it
out and not to be not to be hyperbolic
but if you asked me to make a dream list
of Star Wars directors he rides on
someone can be on it because I wouldn't
dream that they never get it now he'd
like to do it or that they'd ever choose
him to do a fantastically cool out there
awesome choice yes so we're obviously
really excited but we wanted to put this
out there so that we can have you guys
comment below and let us know what you
think of Rian Johnson directing the next
two Star Wars movies possibly yeah
definitely the next one as it should be
announced
so yeah comment below let us know we
really want to know what you guys are
thinking and we'll be commenting back
until next time I'm Ryan and I'm Sam
thanks for watching